thank you thank you all for being here
I'm going to be talking about us putting
my said why you should do text analysis
Python even if you don't want to that's
my name or their case someone's
interested and I'm gonna start cool
why text analysis I mean the talk is
called why you should do text analysis
in Python so I'm gonna be talking a
little bit about text analysis in
general kind of get you all into a feel
of what it is and why it could possibly
be interesting and then move on to why
pythons a cool and fun choice to do this
so personally I mean you can kind of
think of text analysis as data analysis
but your data is just text right and
sure I mean sure it's it's cool it's you
can get jobs out if it's just pretty
neat it's also fun to do but what I
personally found very interesting about
text analysis was the fact that the data
seemed more personal I could that's
where I started I mean I felt that it
wasn't to you know find something
interesting or predict something I was
like well this is just really personal
data and it started off actually with
this messaging app called whatsapp I'm
not sure how super popular it is in
America but back in Asia and Europe it
is very popular I don't me and my
buddies we were all on whatsapp and we
had a whatsapp group which is like six
or seven years long right because it's
like 2010 ish and and one point I
figured out well if I have access to all
of this just textual data all of this
texting I've been doing with my buddies
could I possibly do something fun with
it
so I just broke it up like year by year
and I just so you can also totally
download all of your whatsapp message
data you click on your group chat and
then you do like down send email to and
you can email yourself your entire like
chat history right and you can do this
with Facebook also I think messenger I
wasn't sure but I know you can do it
with whatsapp and I did this then I just
did I broke up every single year right
like 2010 11 so on and so forth and I
started running some basic text analysis
stuff like who's talking the most who's
starting the most conversations on
groups who's doing the most emojis what
cut what are people talking like I'm
gonna start looking how do we find what
people talk about then I found about
things called topic models which allow
you to actually find out topics in text
and it was cool like in the summer
during the World Cup like the soccer
world cup the FIFA Football World Cup we
were talking about football a bit more
and there was
rough summer room you all kind of got
out of relationships they're talking
about girls and stuff of that and was
cool to kind of see how every year we'd
be talking about different things and
how this would go who'd start the most
conversations then we started traveling
and moving around so we had different
time zones so that kind of changed the
dynamics as well and this was what
actually got me started and this was all
just with Python and text files which I
mailed to myself and I was like wow this
is cool this is really neat I'm able to
find out things about the way I talk
with my friends and the kind of words I
use just using simple Python scripts and
then I started getting more into it and
contributing to open source and these
are this is how it started but then I
realize there's a lot of cool things
when I talked about the personal how it
could be very personal for example you
can do all kinds of cool research I
really like to read and at one point
like we're doing plays and so there's
bricks beer and then I was trying to
find out more about text analysis with
Shakespeare right and apparently this
was done by a bunch of folks over at
UPenn right I believe though don't quote
me on that
but they were trying to find out about
other authors who could have possibly
co-authored with Shakespeare and this
has been a problem a problem and
research problem or Restatement in in
the study of Shakespeare for a long time
who could have been like people who are
like Shakespeare it's not even real and
all bunch of crazy stuff but then there
was a strong possibility that someone
else is actually writing with
Shakespeare right and they found out I
think for a bunch of the place I think
was Henry the 7th and 8th and they found
out that the writing style is very
similar to Christopher Marlowe who was
another writer in the same era who did a
bond to the playwright and the way they
did this was actually by building these
what they call author's style graphs or
network graphs where they try to figure
out how many the kind of articles which
these authors were using playwrights
were using in different times and the
kind of words the frequency of words and
just the style of writing and they found
out with the high mean they could giving
like we have a really strong hunch it's
Christopher and then after that like
they had actual literary critics who
were like wow you're pop we're probably
right and they had these really neat
style graphs so you could do research in
English literature with text analysis
you can do a lot whole and this is
another story which I normally like to
talk about some super fun but this was
back in 2016 17 right this is when I
think was right before the term 16
Americ
election so Trump was tweeting a lot a
Donald Trump and what was an interesting
research project or just on a project
figure it was going on was when is Trump
actually using his own phone and
tweeting and when is he using like or
when is his you know his PR team doing
it for him when is it an agency actually
doing these tweets for him and what was
really cool was Trump used to tweet like
this is back in 2016 right just for a
bit of context so it wasn't he wasn't
tweeting in the same free ASSA tea as he
was now but it was so pretty cool
because he was also tweeting from a
samsung galaxy phone right so he was
tweeting from a samsung galaxy phone but
there were also a whole bunch of iPhone
tweets going on as well these were super
nice tweets like thanks for coming back
to the rally and let's make America
great all positive stuff but when he was
tweeting with this galaxy phone right he
was just yelling there are caps and
there's all sorts of things going on and
there were other cool things as well
when Trump normally retweets he doesn't
like retweet using the button he's to go
old-school he still I do RT and then
like get the quotation marks in and like
tweet like that so and these were with a
whole bunch of galaxy tweets and people
are they kind of find out a pattern you
could do like sentiment analysis which
I'll be talking about in a bit so they
used to do sentiment analysis which is a
kind of way of identifying sentiment in
text right to figure out when is it
Trump actually tweeting himself or
someone else is doing it for him and it
was there were other really cool things
this is all text analysis by the way you
can get tweets off the internet really
easy and you can run basic Python tweet
you know analysis programs to figure
this out they also found out that he
wouldn't post links or images much that
was always just like PR team who was
handling that so he just pulls text
usually angry texts but mostly text and
it got even more interesting at one
point they couldn't figure out like all
the people doing this text analysis
weren't sure you know is it actually him
doing it or not and then they found
there's someone who's trying to go
straight
ass Trump which to try to use the same
kind of words and style but not be as
angry so you could actually figure it
out and this this really nice blog post
which goes into the details and you
could actually do this for yourself by
the way now Trump's got himself an
iPhone so it's a bit more difficult ever
since he got into presidential office
cuz but this is before he became the
president right so this is another way
you could do political science analysis
so disorder sociological analysis just
using super simple Python and web
scraping and text analysis so when I
usually say why text analysis you could
pretty much do any kind of textual data
you've also got your own email data
you've got whatever kind of data if you
like certain kind of book or something
you could pretty much analyze any kind
of textual data it has the potential to
be personal so to say and be kind of
like a pet project where you're learning
something cool and you're also fiddling
around and you can write up nice blog
post it was just a lot of fun and I
think that is a huge motivation at least
for me and why I usually like to tell
people why I do text analysis but apart
from that of course you also have more
practical things right like for example
even a spam not spam email filter is
also text analysis it's machine learning
in text when I figure out if something
is spam or not so there's a huge
business side application to this you've
got chat BOTS you've got a whole world
of things which you can possibly do with
text analysis so these are these are
this is a part of the talk where I try
to say you should really check out text
analysis it is very very neat and that's
kind of that part of the motivation I'll
be moving on now to well why python
well why Python of course this is PI
data and I'm sure a lot of people here
know why you should use Python but I
what I would argue is the best reason is
because it's a really good text scraping
language like people used Perl before
this for text scraping or you know just
try to you know scripts for scripting
language but pythons really holding its
own now it is arguably the best
scripting language a quick scripting
language which we can use it just makes
it really good to just work with text
and not just that it when it comes to
for example deep learning or things like
that you've got tends to flow another
really it's a very strong ecosystem I
don't really need to sell the ecosystem
to all a few folks because you would all
be aware of what it call for Python is
in this context but for text analysis
especially when you're comparing with
other are for example if you're gonna
most people would probably have like oh
[ __ ] is our a Python to do this in this
case I think Python really wins because
for text analysis it's great there's
also a lot of libraries which are really
really good for text analysis you've got
industry grade libraries which again I
will be talking about a bit more not
just saying there exists but they do
exist and so it's a combination of the
fact there's a really good ecosystem
especially the whole you know the whole
number
a stack and the pie data stack in
general is really really useful and you
have I mean things like scikit-learn me
look into text classification carries
all of these things Jensen which I'm
also really really big fan of all of
these are really really nifty tools
which are all really easy to use in
Python I'm not saying that other
programming languages don't have these
they do but the ecosystem just ties up
really well in Python also if and if you
have any questions feel free to like
interrupt me in between put your hands
up there's no problem cool
the next part is where is the data I've
already kind of talked about that I
think when I talked about the whole all
the data sources and three examples like
I've talked about Twitter before and my
own personal messages and of course you
have books which you all legally bought
so you have a whole bunch of really cool
data sources but there's you can go one
step further and look for really
structured data on the Internet
one of my personal favorite sources is
reddit I spend too much time on reddit
but apart from just my personal time I
spent on reddit it has quite just for
some context reddit is a new sporting
website where people post articles based
on based on their interests so you have
subreddits for politics sports all kinds
of sports it gets really in taking have
really obscure niche subreddits as well
food traveling there's a whole bunch of
it but the reason I'm talking about is
it's largely textual I mean you do have
images that just a whole bunch of memes
but there's a large textual competent to
Reddit and it's also question answered
based right what this means is that you
can just kind of scrap this and you can
model how people talk to each other
really well you have time stamps also in
a really neat JSON format I mean this is
just one example right read is just one
example
you also have Twitter and you have
Facebook if you so like use it you have
blog post you can also literally just
scrape the Internet there are tools like
beautifulsoup
and which allow you to actually go in
clean HTML files and you can use Python
again as an engine for scraping the
Internet the Internet is literally the
most massive text resource you have now
you have all these kind of more what
I've just talked about so far as like
real data sources right in a sense of
people talking and sharing and you can
model human behavior when you can
also like I said before like downloading
books but it's not just books which you
can text analyze there are text
classification and clustering datasets
there are large like a huge part of
machine learning and text I mean machine
learning in general is just textual
analysis there are a lot of data sets
available on any website like even
caddel has a whole bunch of text
analysis one things like sentiment
analysis movie review analysis there are
a lot of already curated clean data sets
where you don't have to get your hands
dirty but if you do want to get your
hands dirty there's a lot of textual
data it's probably an abundance of it
there's just merely not enough time to
analyze all of it but what's really cool
is it's really really really easy to
find this textual data I'm sure even on
just like on your laptops you would have
some kind of textual data and text files
just around there and it's really easy
to get this so this is what I think I
mean when you talk about where the data
is I'm like other cases other more
traditional machine learning like I'm
gonna throw this really cool Bayesian
neural network cuz you don't know what
exactly you were analyzing right it
doesn't feel way but I think textual
data kind of breaks this and this is
what I really really enjoy about it
pre-processing now so far I've just kind
of very generally been talking about
text analysis and Python and about why I
think it's exciting and but now I'm
gonna go into little more details about
the some of the problems you encounter
when you do textual data analysis and
what do you have to be careful about so
I mean most people would have heard of
the garbage in garbage out kind of thing
right where if you're gonna give really
bad data you're gonna get really bad
results and I think text analysis in
particular this ends up happening a lot
and pre-processing is the most important
part of text analysis I mean it's
probably the most important part of any
kind of data analysis you are doing but
it becomes even more important in
textual analysis because the especially
based on the context I'll give you an
example if you're talking about topic
models which I briefly brought up before
right so I'm gonna talk a little bit
about what exactly these topic models
are so there are probabilistic graphical
models I mean that's like
math science Eid description for them
but these were these probabilistic
graphical models - which is really cool
is if you have lots of unstructured
textual data let's think of you work for
a newspaper agents you have a whole
bunch of newspapers like in digital
format and you want to kind of figure
out what these newspapers are about like
2000 2014 or whatever and you can use
topic modeling and say five topics that
you expect to see five topics and this
machine learning algorithm will go
through your textual data and come out
with five distributional words that
share topics you'd get like sports
politics weather with no input and
you're just giving in your raw textual
data now the thing is if this data is
not cleaned properly you're gonna have a
whole topic it should be with just
pronouns which are completely useless
you know these would be a topic but or
there'd be a lot of numbers where these
things may not be really important and
I'd not add any information but in some
cases this might be really important if
you're trying to model a bot for example
to do a chat bot you'd wanted to know
about pronouns right I mean so based on
your context your pre-processing is
going to be very very different and this
is a very important part of text
analysis so you have a lot of packages
which we'd spend a lot of time to just
focus on the pre-processing part or the
text cleaning part and I'm gonna again
also talk very briefly about that I'd
not been saying a lot that I will be
talking but I promise that we'll be
getting there so that's a little bit
about pre-processing I know this is
important in all kinds of text I mean
all kinds of data analysis but I think
it becomes very very crucial in text
analysis a brief point all these things
which I will also talking about over
here I talked I cover more in more
detail with a lot of code in a tutorial
I did this tutorial yesterday which you
will be able to see the video of and I
will be giving links as well so what I
would like to say is right now you would
not need to worry too much about library
names or particulars I just want to get
you a feel of what exactly this field is
and for the details like what code you
want to be running how you're going to
be doing it and all the textual data
scraping all of that there's there are
tutorials which I written which I will
link to you or you can just watch them
on YouTube after this this is just for
some context before I go on because
there will be more talk about libraries
or code
coming up yep so machine learning in
text so all of the things I've talked
about before like including topic models
they're technically a machine learning
algorithms which are based on text right
and you have a lot of libraries which
are doing the scikit-learn I think is
probably the most popular machine
learning library at least for your more
vanilla machine learning and psychic
learning does have topic modeling and it
does have text classification I talked
earlier about where text classification
might be in handy like the spam not spam
thing is probably a very popular example
of machine learning in text it's a very
classic example there's a salga rhythm
called Gaussian naive Bayes which kind
of figures out what words appear more
often in a certain context and decides
if it's in that class or not for example
in the context of spam or not spam you
would have like words like offer money
massive or whatever and you'd have these
kind of words that's probably spam and
then you'd have a bunch of other words
which are probably not spam so based on
what words tend to appear in spam
e-mails and whatnot you will be building
your classifier this is a machine
learning model I've seen it I've set in
a release really simple manner it's not
this simple there's a bit more approach
to probabilistic model so it figures out
what are the odds of this word being
here or not and it does it so this is
machine learning in text right this is
an example of how you do it and these
algorithms and this was a long time ago
I mean you've had spam filters around
for a long while things are getting a
lot more sophisticated now so what I'm
going to talked about for example you
have tier two text completion as well
which is another example of how your
machine learning in text predictive
capacities in models specifically for
text so there's a whole bundle of these
the but the best part about this is all
of this is available again in the PI
data stack right all of your Bayesian
models if you're using PI mc3 to predict
something or if you're just building a
simple classifier it's I could learn all
of these exist in Python it's very easy
to do this as well this is wordham so
these are where the meetings what you
have written over there and I'm gonna
talk a little bit about word embeddings
it kind of builds on to what I've talked
about earlier about machine learning in
text right so weird
weddings are a kind of machine learning
in text word embeddings what is so huge
problem in text analysis right is that
we keep losing context now why does this
happen when most for example I give you
the example of the whole spam not spam
thing right so what's kind of going on
under the hood is we're counting how
many words appear in documents so if you
have like prize lottery whatever up
hearing the same mail you're counting
these words and you're like oh this is
probably going to go to spam but context
is important we're human beings we don't
just count the currencies of words if
people say to you you understand them
based on the words around them right
that's a very important part of this
so most machine learning algorithms
until a certain time like early 2010
they they lacked this contextual
understanding I mean there were attempts
to you know try and understand it by
looking at oh what words are appearing
around what kind of words and you're
going there it's not like it's
completely context list but it was kind
of poor but then there was this really
neat machine learning algorithm called
word to act which came out in 2013 I
believe was at 15 I think 13 by these
folks over at Google and it was really
really neat what it did was it really
give an understanding a contextual
understanding to what words are now for
you to understand why this is really
cool I have to briefly talk about how
computers themselves understand text the
way computers understand text is not
just through words so it has no
understanding of what words are it only
knows what numbers are so what you do
when you're building these kind of
machine learning algorithms is you map
every word to a number and then you kind
of give these numbers to the computer
and then it understands or makes these
models based on the numbers and these
numbers are represented as rector's
they're vectors because they're a
mathematical construct which tell you
whether certain words appear in a
certain document or not and then you
make decisions based on this now what
word to wag did was it it's basically
word to whack or word to vector so it
created a wick toriel understanding of
words in a vector space so transformed
words from just being a word to a vector
to like a like a mathematical quantity
so what did what does this mean when we
talk with context so this is a really
popular example which you'd find on most
vlogs or most articles about word to ik
but I'm gonna do the same example anyway
because I think it's a really nice
example to explain why we're Tareq is so
cool so when we have like an under it
like a contextual or semantic
understanding of words for example if we
say what is this understanding of the
word king right - man plus woman so you
have like this abstract idea what a king
is and then you know what man and woman
is your abstract ideas of it so if you'd
literally if you'd actually do this kind
of map so to say like King - man plus
woman you'd probably have an intuition
that it's probably Queen right like
you're taking the like the royalty part
is the king thing and then take the man
out a put a woman in it guess it's Queen
now the super neat thing is when the
folks said Google made the made word to
work and then they basically converted
the word wetter for King the word rector
for man and the word lecture for women
and they basically did this Matt so
they're like word to wake of King - word
- a cough man plus were to wake up woman
the new vector that God was closest to
the word vector for Queen so these are
computers or machine learning algorithms
now being able to understand context
like this which i think is really really
incredible and this was also while ago
right around five years ago you can
really imagine things have been getting
a lot cooler in this particular there's
things like fast text and Lda to work
which is like a topic modeling and
vectors basic things are going crazy in
this particular field of understanding
context with machine learning and we can
build a lot more powerful models based
on this I'm gonna now briefly talk about
or not briefly I can talk a bit more
actually about computational linguistics
this is really really cool part of
machine learning and computer science as
well when it comes to language the
traditional study of linguistics for
example would be if you look at a
sentence you want to identify the parts
of speech right you want to figure out
what so now what's a word and like four
different languages in different
contexts this was like linguistic
studies and then there's also other
parts called named entity recognition
which is when you look at a document you
figure out okay this is an organization
this is a place a geopolitical entity
this is a time you have things like this
you can imagine all of this in from
nation would be very useful in the
context of data science right if you
could figure out what is a place or a
thing based on just a word in a sentence
I mean also things like dependency
parsing which is basically you looking
at a sentence and here's parsing the way
the sentence to see a subject object and
you can verbs and you can figure out I
was sent into the structure you can get
intent if someone's asking a question
and you're not sure with just a question
mark at the end of it if it that the
missing understanding intent is also so
you can do all of these things using
computational linguistics right now the
really cool part is there's a Python
package called Spacey which I use a lot
and I like to talk about and I'd talk
about this in my tutorials as well which
a Spacey's SP Acy in case anyone's
interested in doing a quick google
search for something it's a really
really neat Python library which does a
whole bunch of computational linguistics
stuffs really really fast and really
neat its industry grade and I'm gonna
give you normally when I actually had
this slider before someone's like why
don't you show some code and I keep
saying you can use five lines of code to
find some really cool stuff so I thought
I'd actually put down five lines of code
there it is cool so this is a code in my
talk yeah so you have adjectives is it
easy from you look at it over here so
you have adjectives ooh list
and then oh just some context here HP is
basically the first Harry Potter book
and I've run this through the spacy
pipeline this is very easy to do I'll be
showing you the other code for that
later so you can basically run any kind
of document you want towards with these
spacy pipelines and I talked about
computational linguistics how you can
find parts of speech and named entities
here I wanted to basically check what
kind of adjectives was used
what kind of adjectives were used to
talk about Harry so in this context so I
just waited for this for each sentence
and all the sentences in Harry Potter
for word in sentence if that word isn't
that sentence if Harry is that word then
for that particular word can I find all
for child and world children means when
I'm looking at my dependency parsed
sentence as Harry if all the words
associated with Harry if any of them are
objectives dot POS on
scores dart part-of-speech so if the
part of speech of every word was that
which is associated with the word Harry
is an adjective add that to my list
which is empty or on top and then in the
end I just count that and I get the most
common ten words so this is an example
of five lines of code to do some really
neat computational linguistic stuff now
of course you can go on and do a whole
bunch of things this is also kind of
pseudocode it works with some changes
but it's a bit of a pain to do so I'm
not actually running it but this is more
to give you an example of the kind of
things you can do and I think this is
very very neat so it's and this is not
even complex machine learning stuff is
it now it's just basic text analysis now
of course the way these part of speech
tags were found out was using a deep
neural network model which is always
there but it's still basic text analysis
and I think this is very very neat so
now this is my slide where I tell myself
have to kind of sum up ish so the whole
point of this was to kind of give you an
overview into the kind of things you can
do with textual analysis things have got
even more intense by the way there are
some things which you might not find
particularly useful but are really
really cool one of these things which I
really like to talk about is something
called recurrent neural networks
recurrent neural networks are a class of
neural networks
neural networks are a class of machine
learning algorithms which are loosely
modeled after the biological brain in
terms of neurons and their
interconnections is where they conduct
mathematical operations as these links
this is a very overview of what they are
if you're interested I would really
recommend reading about it more but
neural networks are these class of
machine learning algorithms and
recurrent neural networks are one class
of neural networks and these tend to be
really really neat for textual analysis
the reason is because they can
understand they have memory capacity so
to say so there's a class of a recurrent
neural network called an LS TM or long
short-term memory in what this means is
that it kind of tends to remember it
kind of tends to remember the the
context of words that you just mean what
words are around it
how does it use this information of what
words are around in attempts to predict
now we have two kinds of models which we
can which we can use one is what you
call a character level a neural network
and one is what you call the word level
neural emmerich so basically what's
happening is say you have a single
character you can try and predict what
are the odds of a character coming up
after that which is most likely to make
sense so for example if you feed into
this neural network a whole bunch of
Shakespeare right or a whole bunch of
anything actually it'll start to learn
to reproduce that style of that whatever
text you fed in how does it do this it
figures out so for example if the word
is now you just start with a random seat
of bow in a Shakespeare and you probably
have haast or some in the fifteen
hundreds word coming up after that right
now how does it know this it looks at
what are the odds of certain words
appearing after thou based on what's
already been written and it has a
probabilistic model which is very clever
right because of the neural networks in
the way the interlinking happens and it
allows you to kind of reproduce other
styles of text and this is not just
there's a really really nice blog post
which I enjoyed by Andrew karpati called
the unreasonable effectiveness of
recurrent neural networks where he
actually talks about all of the cool
things you can do
he actually fed the entire Linux
codebase into a recurrent neural network
and it was writing code so you have a
machine learning algorithm which is
writing like syntax really correct code
on its own it could write latex sheets
which had to be corrected because latex
is a pain in the butt um point being it
was really really cool you could do a
whole bunch of really not what are the
possible uses of this right now it's
kind of iffy because you it doesn't
really make sense right it's just
generating text but it has a lot of
potential in China to generate X for
like chat pots or conversations it's
also called a neural conversational
model there's a whole bunch of really
potentially right now
we're not sure how exactly can this be
useful but there's a lot of really cool
things just to explore over here and
just these the best part is and this is
my absolute favorite part it's you don't
have to be a researcher to do any of
this stuff there are a lot of tutorials
out there where they tell you literally
step by step this is how you do it and
you just need to do import Pyrrhus
bunch other stuff and that's it and it's
absurdly easy to do all of this on your
own so the the learning curve I mean if
you're just going to be using the
packages and you have some kind of
intuition to what's going on you can
start doing this right away and I think
that's the best part about all of this
Python remains a very good ecosystem for
this the data is easily available
there's a lot of interesting questions
you can try to solve there's also a lot
of jobs in this particular field so I
think it's a very useful skill to start
at least having a look at or starting to
read about or be interested about and
then you can get on more into it and
figure out if you really want to
continue but that is pretty much the
motivation behind this talk to introduce
you all to this world of possibilities
these world of things you can do now I
realize that there's not been much code
or talk of libraries or actual things so
I'm gonna remedy that very briefly so
like I mentioned before during my talk I
have done a text analysis tutorial just
yesterday and the video will be up so
what I do is whatever I've talked about
a bunch of the things like topic models
text classification part of speech and
computational linguistics and text
generation I cover all of these topics
in this tutorial way briefly just trying
to introduce everyone to it in a simple
way so if all any of these things even
sounded remotely interesting I would
really recommend having to look at my
tutorial where I have a lot of other
links where if you want to get into more
detail you can check it out yourself so
I think as a starting point really
you're not sure if you're interested but
you want to check it out you could have
a look at my tutorial how you'd find it
you could I will I this is my Twitter
handle where I usually only tweet about
Python related stuff I have one cat
picture she was like on my laptop I was
writing code so it's kind of code
related right but I do have that but
apart from that it's usually just a
bunch of nerdy stuff you can check this
out where I will also be right
afterwards I will be tweeting my
tutorial like all the code to it the the
github repository so you can check it
out so you might if you are interested
you can follow me on Twitter you can
also follow me on Instagram if you like
lots more cat pictures there though I
hold no code promises but so this is my
social media slash work and my email is
also Bhargav
Vader at gmail.com it is also my github
handle so I am pretty easy to find on
the internet if you want to contact me
or talk to me more about text analysis
if you want resources on where to start
or anything in this general I'm fairly
friendly so please reach out to me I
would love to talk more also yeah I have
written a book about all of this it's
called a natural language processing and
computational linguistics it's published
by packed publishing house if you it so
what it does is all the things I've
talked about I talked about in more
detail with a lot more code examples
resources so if you are interested you
can check it out a lot of my Jupiter
notebooks and the things my code and all
of these stuff are online on github as
well but if you would like to buy the
book that would be totally cool this I
know also if you want the link and I
probably tweet about her I have created
about it so you can find it and I
believe that's it well yeah that's it
thank you very much are there any
questions alright give the mic over
there or
does your tutorial discuss visualization
visualization of these types of results
or would you describe any resources to
go for perimeters about that sure so the
question is about visualization and
that's a very very good question because
that's a huge part of any kind of
analysis in general right now a transfer
question the best this particular
tutorial which should find doesn't but
on the same repository I have a topic
modeling tutorial where I have a lot of
visualizations I also have an entire
chapter on my book if you want more
visualizations but that being said there
are unde ancient it's always a good
resource and it depends on the kind of
visualization you want to do I
particularly I work mostly with topic
models or what I'm pretty good at so I
know a lot of resources for topic models
Jennsen would be a PI LD Avis is a
Python package which does LD a
visualizations of course you'd have
Seaborn Matt pop up all those like in
you'd have like tutorials which talk
about that but specifically for text and
I mean you have word bubbles those are
super popular and there's a Python
package for word bubbles as well
otherwise I would recommend Jensen if
you just search up Jensen visualizations
they have a visualization for t-sne
which is a way of doing clustering
they're using text as well they have
Association for topic models for word to
whack for classification Jensen is what
I would recommend also the hub
utilizations for training these
processes you can see how well it's
being trained so I would recommend
searching up Jensen visualizations this
is what I'm aware of I'm sure there's a
whole bunch of other stuff out there but
this is what I would definitely know
about about visualizations in general
what's the major class of problems that
you've encountered things that bug you
on like a day-to-day basis while you're
doing text analysis and what kind of
efforts are you aware of that exist to
solve those problems sure so the
question is about what kind of problems
bug me on a day to day basis with text
analysis and what are possible ways to
deal with this so unfortunately I mean I
get Ashley asked it's interesting that
he asked this question because most
times when I'm in color these problems
are actually at conferences when I give
a talk or a tutorial when people come up
to me and they tell me about their
problems and they ask me how to solve
and the reason I'm mentioning this is
because I've been working in research
for pretty much most of my life this
means that I don't usually and I'm not
ready
and they're also Python packages I'm
contributing to and developing too so I
don't work with many text analysis
projects or problems I'm usually working
on the tools behind making them which
means that I'm actually not so there are
some things I am aware of which would be
actually from talking to people who
worked on this and most common place is
dirty data where data is just not an it
sanitation is probably the biggest deal
sanitation is classification or labeling
and in most cases this is the biggest
problem because the most the more useful
text analysis algorithms are a
classification are super wised right and
this is usually a problem because
annotation is not done well there's a
Python package I talked about space see
earlier on which is also a lot in my
tutorial they have this annotation tool
called prodigy prodigies prodigies
awesome I totally dig it a space see in
general has a lot of really useful tools
prodigy is very good for solving
annotation problems because I would
argue that annotation is probably the
biggest problem dirty data the fact that
because a lot of times people are the
ones doing the sound which is totally
cool I mean people are cool right but
the thing is it doesn't always work out
well depending on how well it's people
are paid to do this or the tools
sometimes it's just on Excel and it's
not always neat so I think just the fact
and this is not just text analysis right
this is all data analysis you have
problems with annotation you have
problems with but in the context of text
analysis prodigy is a very good tool to
solve annotation which is a big problem
apart from that I think apart from
English
not many languages are supported as well
I spent the last two and a half years in
France so I would get I would talk to
her and I was traveling about in Europe
talking doing this conference I'm doing
these confident talking about this and
it would be cool because I would like in
depending on the country people that
have different problems based on their
language so they would come and say that
hey in French there's like a whole bunch
of models but in Spanish so it's not
right and that's kind of linked to
market size right so it's it depends on
that I mean I was at PyCon Lithuania and
they were like there's no really good
Lithuanian language models and I'm like
I'm sorry about that this it's just a
problem right so you have things like
this were particularly niche problems
for certain languages it becomes more
difficult to deal with particular cases
but the problems seem to be more or less
the same annotation being the biggest
problem also knowing I mean I think in
general when you're prone to experience
olve a problem being very clear about
the expectations of what you can solve
and what you are getting because a lot
of times when I'm consulting or talking
to people it's from people who are
outside the realm of data science so
they would say this sounds like it's a
problem which can be solved and you look
at and you're like no not really
so I think being a bit not getting ahead
of yourself and you're looking at a
problem and seeing whether text analysis
is actually a way to do this is a huge
part so I mean I know this is not a very
concrete answer but I would say just
kind of be careful about what know the
extent of the problems like topic models
are not gonna find you some kind of
hidden magical topics what it's good at
is finding a large overview of the texts
you have right so knowing what kind of
things to use I mean these are it's very
generic but I've noticed that most of
the problems are related to this bad
annotation or data not knowing what kind
of problems you can solve and if you're
working with more obscure languages then
it's gonna be just difficult getting the
data for this like work to work which I
talked about before they're excellent
models for English not so X and for
other languages so you have these
problems if you're working only in
English and scalability is also a
problem but again any data analysis
problem has a scalability problem so I
suppose these are general good points to
look at but maybe we can talk in more
detail I can tell you more details about
like what other people I know who've
done
what problems they have personally I
have not faced too many because I'm
usually not I'm working on the research
side of things so things are a bit
different but I suppose this would be
general advice anybody else yeah how do
you deal with spelling mistakes oh this
is a good one
so spelling mistakes no there's actually
so this is why I wouldn't think of it as
like the whole so you will just like
really practically I'll give you some
examples I had to actually this is good
because this is kind of link now and
spelling mistakes is actually a problem
which does come up so I was once working
with this really massive data set of
academic researchers it's called a
Microsoft academic graph and what
happens is it basically tells you who's
collaborate with who and how they've
collaborated and there was a huge bunch
of text analysis involved in this
because of people's names and I was
trying to figure out how people and
people misspell things like this and
names can be complicated one way is
something just called like word diff so
you just look at like you just check how
close it is so you have word similarity
bird similarity not based on context but
now this becomes really difficult if you
have a three letter word which is
misspelled right because you'd have like
66% similar so and it's just kind of
difficult to deal with this now the
words math said it becomes easier to
deal with these kind of spelling
mistakes because you'd look at how
similar it is you'd say oh this word is
not in your vocabulary suitable kappa so
like normally when you start a text
analysis project with a large body of
text you count all the unique words
being used in that body of text so
yesterday in the tutorial i was doing
after all the data cleaning of 300
Australian newspaper articles there were
5,400 unique words which is really small
by the way but this was after a lot of
pre-processing on a small data set but
you have vocabularies and in your
vocabularies and one way you can do is
you can actually match this with
existing
like vocabularies you can check how many
are not in vocabularies look at words
and like manually sort them this is one
way you can do it which is more
time-consuming that is so you look at
you know what we're just about correctly
you check which ones are so you have to
do a double check over here another way
if some things are like weird if which I
talked about this something
recalled I think diff lib or something
like that or which basically does this
reduces levenshtein distance which to
basically find out this is basically
just checking how close a word is to
another word so these are ways you can
find commonly misspelled words so
there's a bunch of ways there's no real
100% answer because that's a human
mistake so to say I mean it is a human
mistake and I mean of course computers
can make the same mistakes but the
nature of the error is human and these
are two ways I can think of from the top
of my head to deal with this I you
weren't using both I think it's called
DIF Lib is what I'm thinking right now
is the name of this library so this is
all I would look for commonly misspelled
words and try to figure it out but just
on the wing at the end of the day I mean
you just can't have to deal with it more
or less Python and what anything Python
can do right now that are can't oh okay
that's the question sure
so the question is about Python versus R
um so the thing is I'm really really a
Python guy like I've been using Python
pretty much all my life and I can code
in are like gun against my head I will
do it but I haven't done it enough for
me to be able to answer your question
very well I do know they do have some
topic models for sure and they would
have text classification but in my
experience and I have done brief topic
modeling using R because there there was
like there was a need implementation of
topic models in R which is why I checked
it out but I found maybe it's also
because this is the fact I'm out of time
I've spent using Python but I found text
great like scraping like for example
opening text files loading text files
into files and then all of that iPhone a
lot easier in Python in just in terms of
your text manipulation because I think
it's just very easy to manipulate just
text strings like you know like strings
string manipulation is really really
easy in Python it could be easy in R in
fact if there's anybody else in the
audience who have actually used R for
text analysis as unlikely as it may be
it would be cool to have someone weigh
in on this because I would just say that
I've not used R enough I do know they
have some class of machine learning
models which are okay to do it but I've
not used it enough and for when it comes
to just scripting as a language python
is better than R that I can say quite
objective ish
so it's what I would like to say if
anyone elects to weigh in on this not a
lot I've done some text analysis in art
it's the pre-processing that's really
right well I think so yeah and I can't
speak to the full class of available
models out there right in each in each
language but the pre-processing is just
so much easier Python yeah so that that
could change things and things like
stringer you know being developed
actively I'm sure that's on its way to
being changed but yeah that's that's my
experience I saw a couple of hands go up
over here in case um yeah hey can you
give us a sense of when you're starting
with the problem you you're in an
unsupervised scenario you don't really
know like what exactly you should be
doing do you have a set of steps that
you take to kinda like give structure to
these sort of documents that you have or
to try to kind of like explore like what
direction should I go in with this this
corpus if you are not really sure how to
how to proceed there sure so the
question is if you have a whole bunch of
unstructured textual data what are the
rough kind of pipeline or steps you
would do to understand this data set a
little bit better I actually this is a
good question I'm gonna say the same
thing I've said a lot of times this talk
which is topic models that could be
because I used I probably overuse them a
little bit but when it comes to an
unsupervised method of trying to find
some kind of latent information in text
that is the literal purpose of topic
models so I talk about these a lot on my
github repository so what I normally do
when I look at like some kind of I would
first to run using spacy
I would try and build my corpus I would
get rid of punctuation stop words so
stop words or words which are not
usually very useful information in text
I talk about it more in my tutorial if
everyone else is interested but I try to
get rid of stop words I limit eyes get
rid of numbers and then I run topic
modeling this is what I do and then I
look at like say four five topics then I
say oh this so this is the rough breakup
of my corpus it again largely depends on
the size
your corpus right I mean if I'm like if
it's really really big I would be a bit
more liberal and say 40 or 50 topics and
then we'll manually inspect these topics
very briefly and they give you a really
good idea like for example a newspaper
example again before if you don't know
the context from at the Australian
newspaper data set I use you can find
the context like really fast like you
can just look at these topic models
after you've been like wow that's what
it's about
and then after that based on your
problem you'd get more into it now that
being said topic models are kind of
outdated they I mean the original paper
by David Blake who came up with the
first topic model for text came out in
2003 and he's actually been actively
doing work on the C's over at Columbia I
believe right now and he's doing a lot
of cool work on topic models to keep it
more relevant more robust there's also
something called TSN II which is used
for clustering and I believe it's been
used for words quite well as well I
think that's a cool way of doing it and
that's a visual way of doing it so if
you want to get some visual thing going
on or there it's pretty cool but I
personally think if it's unstructured
completely unstructured topic models
will tell you say there are five topics
it'll tell you it'll basically break up
every document into one of these five
topics a combination of them so for
example if you had this really bizarre
article about I don't know the day
Hillary Clinton went to the beach and
was really rainy and she played soccer
this should be like 30% politics 30%
sports 30% weather possibly based on the
breakup of words but this still gives
you some kind of useful information
right like what kind of documents are
appearing in my really massive corpus
that all of the articles in my massive
corpus should probably be in one of
these five topics so this gives you a
good overview and then based on this you
can throw more sophisticated things at
it like work to work or whatever based
on the kind of problem you want to solve
right or if it's just annotation or
whatever so I would think that this is a
kind of a good way to start dealing with
unstructured data which is clean it and
after you kind of get it a little clean
run a topic Marv will re clean it and
keep doing this process until you get as
useful information as you can and then
get into the more fancier things this is
what I normally do and I think it works
fairly well but in most cases you have
usually have a very clear business
problem on what you
to do and based on that you would work
differently usually that has talked
about annotation before that remember
that ends up being the most important
part I think annotating and prodigy
which I talked about before it's a very
cool tool you have to pay for it
submitted to it's a software which you
by the same folks who made prodigy are
the creators of Spacey which is an
open-source Python library which is very
very cool and they also do displace in a
bunch of other things basically there's
a lot of really cool tools you can use
to get an idea of your data but after
that's kind of up to you based on your
particular problem and suppose all right
Thank You Bhargav that was a wonderful
talk
[Applause]